a video went ridiculously viral I got on
the internet about a kid trying to get a
job with us a [ __ ] internship on
internship is on my resume to play I
love how you looked as if like your
alarm is gonna stop me from doing this
setup I know I'm buying chocolate listen
this kid hacked it this interview
meeting opportunity fairy tale ending
growth hacking strategy is a very
worthwhile video for all of you please
pay attention do the homeworks teams
let's let's uh let's link some of the
coverage and the reddit thread and the
other things that came along with this
incredible interview with this wonderful
kid who is now got something very good
coming up in the future so man you made
it you figured it out tell me the whole
story I'm gonna spell it out for you G
Oh Oh G go to Google and type in how do
I make money how do I start a business
there's a lot of things you can do but
are you willing to bleed out of your
[ __ ] eyes for your dream answer is
you're not cuz you're full of [ __ ] cuz
like a voice what do you do i no no yep
so I pretty much just do other stuff and
pretty much design
if I stay too long I get it so in that
vigil will communications i got bf8
pretty much so I'm whispering in your
yearbook you know virtually yes calling
all creators right now need to create a
content army so I just reached out to on
my Instagram and like you know I just
offered him some value like I know like
video kids like they need like graphics
just to save them time someone came in
I'll do so like Lord their graphics for
you or something whatever and he was
down with it they didn't end up like
working out how we wanted it to but like
we kept in touch and everything and from
there I I was just trying to figure out
how I could do the same thing he did but
like my own way because I know you guys
said like you have a hundred and fifty
out to 4,000 views I'm like how am I
gonna stand out and I know you like rap
music hired me not simply cuz I emailed
in no choir rebuffed ozonator secret you
won't find this and diary they made the
video yes super super the way I like it
yeah once their studio that's probably
expensive I got so he rented studio
space yeah yeah where there's this yes
did song there where do you live I live
in cities mm-hmm
yeah so I pretty much do the video I
wasn't gonna put it up like when I some
the application to you guys it was like
a private kind of link to that yeah
but the tomcee kid like i asked him like
what he thought about it he's like man
this could go viral go figure
like I mean like like it's cool in
Norway like since I'm just kind of silly
I get it so people might hate on it or
wherever but tickets advice I put it on
YouTube no traction like it's like super
slow I'm like digging on LinkedIn and
trying to figure out like who I can
email here just because I felt like I
just needed somebody to see you know
yeah of course
my friend of mine is like a man like you
want me to post it on reddit and like
I'm familiar with writing like I know
like if you didn't do something already
like the internet notices it so we toss
it on reddit like 30 minutes get like
150 views I'm going like nuts Canyon
really focused I get it we all feel that
after it happens so so it went to 150
views and then what literally you're
just refreshing every like a little bit
with this iPhone with this throughout my
education I perform with this on daily
basis I beat that innate you've been in
haze for a week yeah so now you're here
yes so so what uh where people reaching
out to you that you haven't talked to in
a while like
[Music]
[Laughter]
I get it I get it
get yeah of course I mean one viral
video as you you're smart you get it
like there's a lot of people that have
done that it's about what you do next
the next the next the next so what would
you like to happen you want to get a job
here yeah
you'll move down here my house but I'm
cool we're moving out working for you
yeah I'll pull weight then okay and what
do you want to do design and learn all
the other stuff yeah designs your core
skill that you've had and then you want
to learn whatever the [ __ ] else you can
learn every time I get behind I'll make
a souffle
I hit fix your homie website I can't
even illustrate and you can create this
size and take it personal I know this
realtor please Tyler get me Andy yep yep
he just asked me like to like see what I
could do it with like a video screen PO
so I just basically just like this kind
of concept for him mm-hmm I like that
you know
then if you like yeah I like it I think
I could do that stop saying something he
mopped up for up that Boehner ass you
see this it's noise yeah I like the
second piece a lot I was about as pretty
impressed with the southern for you
actually did you see that I haven't yet
yeah you did it quickly
it's from baby V yeah sounds and gifs we
please keep calling gifts I'm kidding
I'm kidding I'm kidding I know it's been
officially rebranded but I'm still
pissed about it um okay I mean where are
we at with design so I know you got a
couple people yeah in Chicago that we
have there's a female Monica Cesar
starts this week okay hope to synthesize
that footage on fit and if your opinion
you'll realize I'm really when what's
that pal gonna watch it I am not that
kind of fit listen we need a hard core
design bruising I know when in conflict
there was it like what you just made
there and if he's impressed if we can
pull it up we can move quickly here can
you can you pull it up can you pull it
up while we talk I mean I think that's
our biggest need right now yes I mean
right yeah and then there's the
secondary I've always liked the media
account creators right would you yeah of
course I do this is from dailyvee 295
and this is just that content
around like striking things I thought
you said throughout that just like
medium stuff for that but enough of my
lips moving high on me let's get up
prove it the each other's real funny
yeah man I think we should do it I think
it's a funny story for everybody on the
internet I think I think I think he's
clearly got the skills to be able to do
it and more importantly I think we can
motivate millions of people to go and
get theirs too
I think I think we owe it to him and I
think you know to them to make this hire
I think it'll make the full circle feel
real good when can you start
I would ask for month it's like yeah you
got stuff to do once you gotta figure
out where you're gonna live and
everything yeah yeah all right so why
don't you guys talk details of like
price and everything too
so he can have some time to figure out
but I would I'd be okay with him joining
team you're welcome so why don't you
guys talk details right now while I go
to my next meetings and let me know if
there's any friction if he can afford
they can't afford it like anything
that's logistically needed all right
you're welcome man Congrats good
you guys go jam and that's how you do it
that's pretty cool I got I got I got I
got internship on internship it's on my
resume in that vigil well communications
I can be a face every time I get by my
computer I'll make a souffle I
fix your homey website I can even
illustrate I can